quelle place pour la france dans l'otan
une place de choix en 1949
puisque la france faisaient alors partie
des pays fondateurs de l'organisation du
traité atlantique nord
[Musique]
alors bien sûr ce sont surtout les
etats-unis qui ont impulsé et fonder
cette alliance de 12 pays
tous prêts à agir contre l'ennemi russe
qui occupe alors la moitié de l'europe
pourront décoller en moins de deux
minutes sauf qu'en 1966 le général de
gaulle décide de quitter le commandement
intégré de l'otan
un geste d'indépendance vis-à-vis des
états unis alors que la france vient
tout juste de se doter de l'armé
nucléaire
en raison de l'évolution intérieure et
extérieure des pays de l'est
le fait est que l'occident ne se trouve
plus actuellement menacés comme il
l'était quand le protectorat américain
fut installée en europe sous le couvert
de l'otan
pour autant la france participe toujours
aux opérations de l'organisation comme
en yougoslavie dans les années 90
ou en afghanistan dans les années devenu
un pied dedans un pied dehors
jusqu'en 2009 tournant où la france qui
fait son grand retour dans le
commandement intégré de l'alliance avec
nicolas sarkozy la france sera plus
influentes pourquoi parce que les
absents ont toujours tort ce geste c'est
surtout renoncer à l'indépendance
géopolitique de la france pour certains
au moment de la guerre en irak
on a été capable du français de dire non
et bien en quelques jours on va brader
cette indépendance d'une organisation
sous domination américaine
la voix de la france à l'intérieur de
l'otan aura beaucoup de mal à se faire
entendre et dix ans plus tard sans
évoquer la place de la france
emmanuel macron remettent en question
l'otan en tant qu'organisation il estime
que nous assistons à sa mort cérébrale
et pointe les désaccords géopolitique
entre l'europe et les états unis
[Musique]